today
denmark is one of the first countries
lifting all the covered restrictions
norway sweden are going to follow
probably in a week other countries are
also lifting restrictions uk ireland
i'd like to have your view on this how
advisable is it to lift the restrictions
before a peak in omicron is reached and
while the spread is is still massive and
as you said there are new omicron
variants too that we do not know so much
about
what's the danger of an upsurge
afterwards and perhaps if you can
address to
what at what point is it reasonable for
countries to actually start lifting um
restrictions
thank you
thank you canela and we'll start with dr
maria van kerkov
so thanks for the question um
you know in the last seven days uh more
than 22 million cases were reported to
who
largely driven by the omicron variant
this variant of concern that is
circulating the globe we know that case
reporting is an underestimate and it's
not a great proxy for really
understanding
virus circulation at the moment
what is more concerning right now for me
and i think for us is that in the last
four weeks we're seeing a sharp increase
in deaths around the world and in all
regions um two regions are relatively
stable in terms of the numbers of deaths
that they've reported in the last week
but four regions are reporting
increasing
trends
in deaths and that shouldn't be
happening at the present time when we
have tools that can actually prevent
this
what who has continued to recommend is
the use of the tools we have at hand
countries are in very different
situations around the world we have no
one solution that fits all what our
recommendations are
um is to apply the tools to handle two
aspects of this virus this dangerous
virus that is circulating one is to
increase vaccination coverage so that we
protect individuals from developing
severe disease and death we get patients
into the clinical care pathway because
early clinical care saves lives and at
the same time do what we can to reduce
the spread of this virus using tools
that are readily available masks
physical distancing improving uh and
investing in ventilation where we live
where we work where we study
supporting people to work at home
investing in surveillance and testing
all of that still applies
now how countries use these tools is up
to them but we are urging caution
because many countries have not gone
through the peak of omicron yet many
countries have low levels of vaccination
coverage with very vulnerable
individuals within their populations and
so now is not the time
to lift everything all at once we have
always urged
always urged caution in applying
interventions as well as lifting those
interventions in a steady and in a slow
way piece by piece because this virus is
is quite dynamic
and it's still we still have a lot to
learn from it even though we know a lot
about it we still don't know all
and so our advice is to use a
comprehensive approach and to use the
tools that are at hand
again countries are going to have to
apply that to the situation that they're
in taking into consideration this the
spread of the virus
the population level immunity that they
have in terms of past infection as well
as vaccination coverage and in
particular coverage among those who are
most at risk
their capacities to respond
the the relationship that they have with
the people within their communities so
all of those are factors that countries
have to take into consideration so we
have no one solution fits all but we are
urging countries to continue to use the
tools at hand to reduce the spread as
well as reduce morbidity and mortality
from this virus